das ist Schnee und der ist genauso cool
wie Siemens Energy meine Damen und
Herren und da befinden wir uns heute
ja ich habe super geschlafen weil Josef
neben mir tatsächlich die ganze Nacht
geschnarcht hat wir befinden uns heute
bei Siemens Energy meine Damen und
Herren das hier ist das Training Center
wir sind übrigens in Berlin
das ist das Trainingscenter von Siemens
Energy in Berlin ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht so ganz was mich erwartet dafür
haben wir allerdings Studierende Azubis
Lernende ganz ganz nette Menschen das
heute ein bisschen zeigen werden stell
dich mal ganz kurz vor mit einem Wort
nicht talentin Elektrotechnik einbaut
ich mag Angeln und Nico ich bin bei der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr
ich bin Luca ich weiß gar nicht was ich
hier gerade mache schalten Sie lieber ab
wir gehen jetzt auf jeden Fall rein
schauen so ein bisschen was uns erwartet
ich habe nur gehört wir machen ein paar
challenges paar witzige Sachen schauen
uns ein paar Räumlichkeiten an wird's
noch ein bisschen Nerven vielleicht
Raum Nummer eins sehen wir euch heute
zeigen werden das sieht mir alles noch
ganz viele Sachen aus und ich gar keine
Ahnung habe das einzige was ich vorhin
schon gehört habe ist das hier drin wir
blenden euch jemand Quiz ein was denkt
ihr welche Person saß hier schon drin
ihr habt 10 Sekunden Zeit um zu raten
[Musik]
jetzt Angela Merkel habt ihr Nitro
drunter gebaut ja klar top da wir uns
jetzt allerdings hier gerade schon im
Werkstattraum von Siemens Energy
befinden meine Damen und Herren habe ich
mir gedacht mach mal doch direkt eine
kleine wer liegt besser Challenge mit
Melanie wir haben hier jeder eine Tüte
vorbereitet mit Gegenständen einerseits
Alltagsgegenstände aber auch Siemens
Energy Gegenstände und wir schauen jetzt
wer besser lügen kann ich habe hier
einen kleinen Berliner Bernd der ist
natürlich
lila weißen
ja du hast ein Berliner Bären gelogen
ich habe hier wie es sich natürlich für
Siemens Energy gehört eine Dose dirty
kannst du die mal aufmachen ja klar
ich bin kein Experte aber ich glaube du
lügst tragische Wände jeden Mittag immer
5 Liter dirty das Übel gesund ich habe
was sehr praktisches damit kann man
wunderbar Schlüsselbänder irgendwo an
einem Gürtel fixieren und zwar ein
Karabiner kannst du den mal so auf und
zu machen
ich habe als nächsten Gegenstand einen
Hammer auf dem Tisch
das ist kein Hammer nein das war meine
Hand
ist für die Beauty Kategorie gedacht und
das ist ein wunderschöner Lippenstift
ja
was ist das ich habe hier
den Playboy
Oktober
oktober also die Seiten sind glaube ich
zu fest für ein Playboy du kennst dich
damit
2016 du lügst
ersten faultiermagazin erste Challenge
3:3 von daher müssen wir mal schauen
wenn man noch ein paar andere challenges
vorbereitet welche schlussendlich
gewinnt Luca oder Siemens nächste
Challenge meine Damen und Herren ich
befinde mich mit Mona die ebenfalls
Azubi ist wir machen jetzt eine äh nicht
lachen Challenge und immer wenn einer
von uns beiden lacht müssen was machst
du beruflich ich studiere dual hast du
mich gerade
eigenen Töpferkurs geflogen habe mich im
Ton vergriffen
den kannte ich schon ein Neutron steht
vor einem Club sagt der Türsteher sorry
heute nur geladene Gäste kann ich auch
schon
mein Onkel hinterlässt ja mein Onkel
hinterlässt eine Konservenfabrik und ich
Erbse
ey da du weißt ich liebe dich
habe mir gestern ein neues Dach gekauft
es fällt mir sehr schwer allerdings hat
Mona die zweite Challenge für die Azubis
gewonnen jetzt befinden uns allerdings
hier schon im vierten floor von daher
haben wir hier ein ganz anderes
Prozedere gerade das ist Team Typ du
kannst doch ganz kurz erklären was ist
überhaupt alles ist wir sind hier in
einem Elektro Labor wir haben die
meistens immer vom leckersatz gesagt die
Schaltpläne sagt vorgeben oder muss sie
selber stellen aber ich verstehe
tatsächlich nichts von was ich
allerdings kann ist Lego und das ist
tatsächlich die nächste Challenge die
wir machen dafür haben wir nämlich hier
vorne also ich nicht sondern die anderen
haben da vorne hier schon was
vorbereitet weil wenn ich das selbst
hätte könnte ich natürlich bin
zusammenbauen und da machen wir jetzt
gleich weiter mit der nächsten Challenge
wir müssen hier bei der dritten Teo
oh mein Gott das geht gar nicht
ich versuche gerade zu schummeln aber es
geht nicht
nein ich weiß nicht mehr wo das Teil ist
ich hatte einen Plan aber man kann die
nicht richtig man erfüllt die nicht
richtig das sieht für euch jetzt richtig
leicht aus oder
ob die reden auch nicht mit uns so wie
ich dich hasse würde mein Handschlag
verweigert hast
nein aber kein Scheiß
oh mein Gott
ich habe drei Reifen ich habe den
letzten nicht rangekriegt ich habe den
letzten scheiß Reifen nicht
viel zu wenig Zeit
hier stehen Maschinen aber ich bin
eigentlich die wahre Maschine
Unentschieden ey krank wie schlecht du
bist nächste Challenge meine lieben
Freunde ich sitze hier mit Tip immer
noch im gleichen Raum wo wir hinten
gerade dieses Lego oder so komisch
zusammengebaut haben wir tatsächlich
gerade einen Schaltkreis vor uns ja auch
eingeschaltet ist der läuft auch weil
die Diode leuchtet grün allerdings
bekommen wir gleich Brillen aufgesetzt
und unser unparteiischer Schiedsrichter
Jost Jost kommt gleich an und klippt
random zwei Elemente dieses Kreislauf
ist hier raus pack die hin wir kriegen
die Brillen auf und müssen die wieder
rein Klippen
ich kann ja eigentlich jetzt schon den
Punkt geben los geht's
ist es dann Unentschieden oder sagen wir
wer es näher dran sondern
haben wir hier noch den Schaltkreis
Profi am Start dafür dass du dabei warst
danke dass du dabei warst tief äh ich
ich mache mal den Punkt ich darf groß
und schön verkünden dass ich die
Challenge eher gewonnen habe nicht
komplett gewonnen allerdings habe ich es
geschafft von daher danke Team für dein
für dein dass du dabei warst fünfte und
letzte Challenge meine Damen und Herren
ich stehe mit Nico und wir befinden uns
hier im Community space für meine Josef
wundervoll wenn man die Mülltonne da
unten in der Ecke
das mache ich aus dir bei dieser
Challenge
ja okay ich glaube da hast du mir was
ganz gutes noch gegeben also ich glaube
es ist ich bin mir da sehr sicher dass
das gerade ein Pfeile ist
Schraubenschlüssel das ist doch bestimmt
so eine so eine winkende Katze also so
eine
so eine so die immer so ein Schauspieler
bei dem beim dem Asiaten meines
Vertrauen
mein erster Gedanke was ist ein
elefantenspielzeug ich sag es sind
Elefant oh ja zum reinpusten ach diese
diese Tröte Dinger für
Silvester und Karneval wahrscheinlich ja
die Sache ist aber wenn ich jetzt meins
auch richtig habe dann ist unentschieden
aber dann habe ich ja dennoch gewonnen
oder
was ist denn das
also es könnte ein Salz Pfefferstreuer
sein
boah aber
da ist nichts offen sondern gewürzding
aber hier ist auch ein Knopf es ist eine
Taschenlampe es ist eine Taschenlampe oh
mein Gott aber krank wir haben beide
alles erraten dennoch meine Damen und
Herren ist die letzte Challenge
unentschieden ausgegangen jeder hat drei
Sachen richtig von daher Endergebnis wir
rechnen immer kurz zusammen das war mein
Tag heute weil sie als energy meine
Damen und Herren danke schön dass ihr
mich heute so ein bisschen rum geführt
habt deswegen alles gezeigt habe die
ganze Räumlichkeiten ähm seid auf jeden
Fall cool drauf danke für die Challenge
ist wenn ihr auch Bock habt hier bei
Siemens ändert die coole Sachen zu
machen vielleicht sogar eine Ausbildung
zu starten dann checkt auf jeden Fall
mal den Link unten in der Video
Beschreibung ab da findet ihr alle
weiteren Informationen und wir geben uns
jetzt zurück nach Köln
tatsächlich sogar herzlichen Dank danke
schön das ist der Siemens Energy vs Luca
Daumen hoch wie Champions
[Musik]